it took 10 years but finally it happened
on Tuesday during the agricultural
committee MEP is agreed on a European
legislation setting common rules to help
contain outbreaks of animal diseases and
fights growing antibiotic resistance in
animals and humans the same day
secretary-general yen stoltenberg told
em eps of the Foreign Affairs Committee
that NATO is striving for a more
constructive relationship with Russia
and of its new monitoring mission in the
Aegean Sea NATO does not seek
confrontation we do not want a new Cold
War dialogue is not a sign of weakness
dialogue is a sign of self confidence in
what we agreed with Turkey at the
defense ministry meeting was that if the
people were rescued by NATO if they come
from Turkey we can return them to Turkey
with high rates of unemployment in
Europe the European jobs network known
as your res provides a welcome mine of
employment opportunities and services
for job seekers willing to move to
another European country for work a new
piece of legislation is underway to
improve the network make it easier to
find work abroad and match a large pool
of job vacancies and CBS in plenary
parliament called for cohesive EU
economic policy to make efforts to
reduce budget deficit possible bolster
Europe's economies and bring urgently
needed job creation and sustainable
growth also in plenary MEP s exchanged
views with Commission President
jean-claude Juncker and President of the
Council Donald Tusk talk centered on the
deal brokered with UK Prime Minister
David Cameron during the latest summit
ahead of the in or out of the EU
referendum set to take place on june the
23rd
my